oh
he clips the freaking blue screen
see none of this looks real to me agreed
it's the faces it's the same actress
playing all these very very different
characters
there are so many people that are saying
that the she-hulk vfx are absolute
garbage what is up with this like why is
it that every trailer has to be like
controversial or something
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 25 off of each pair
of vessies
what's up welcome back to another
episode of vfx artist react i was
rolling into work today and i saw a
trash pile on the side of the road and i
was like what the heck i opened it up
and there was clint just sitting there
in some trash it's me guys what's up
i don't live in our house anymore
live in the trash can outside well thank
you so much for joining us today man i'm
excited we're gonna be looking at the
hulk the she-hulk hulk yeah we've had a
request from a lot of people to take a
look at love death and robots and it's
funny how now that it's finally
happening you're not prepared for the
one clip we're gonna watch
well okay no i'm uh i've been trying to
get us to react to this show for a long
time and i've watched every single
episode of season three except for the
one that you guys want to look at today
you haven't seen it yet haven't you
found it
i literally was gonna watch it last
night but i was like i'm too tired did
you watch every episode in season three
no i this is the only one
look at this so everyone has been saying
hey the last episode of love depth and
robots season three is uh super cool and
it looks 100 real i wouldn't say it
looks real i mean it looks incredible it
looks realistic i think there's a
difference between something looking
realistic and something looking real
because a lot of this looks realistic
like the tree awesome plants foliage
awesome oh look at the style though look
at the style in the plants the little
squigglies the color schools yeah the
wacky wacky plants there is some
stylization obviously but stylization
takes it away from real
from a cinematic standpoint they're
trying to capture and render this image
as if it was real okay yes you're
talking about like from the filmmaking
perspective of like everything is
grounded in reality the camera is
somewhere being held by a person there's
a real lens with real focal lengths
going on but the aesthetic and the style
takes it away from the reel
see none of this looks real to me agreed
it's the faces even the armor you know
like it looks good it looks realistic
but it doesn't look real well i'm just
saying these shots we're watching right
now with some cool like production
designers and makeup artists you could
totally accomplish what they're
utilizing the cg for
is
to like expand that into like the more
otherworldly moments like the water
dancing and like the underwater scenes
and stuff like that
this looks like a matte painting to me
nothing's moving in the foreground it
looks way more painful you're right this
style yeah yo this is a painting like
shifted style straight up this is a
painting and just a little bit around
him and a little bit of the brush on the
other side where the body fell into that
is rendered to match the style and the
lighting but everything else in the
frame is a painting they're doing it
very selectively where it's like a
couple elements of foliage will move but
the rest is still a painting like the
foliage there in the bottom the fern
there that's a cg fern but i think the
ferns directly behind him are painted
such a strange choice to shift your
style just a little bit like that but it
fits it looks beautiful is it called
impressionistic style yeah
impressionistic is i think the right
word for this yeah see like all of this
so far that i'm seeing has a little bit
of that impressionistic style to it that
makes it less real but it's still
realistic i would even say it's more
realistic than avatar at points you know
i think it's because the style helps it
the style absolutely helps the style
takes it and then just goes
yeah
granted yeah there's a few shots that
you're like ah cg my rule of thumb is
that anytime your cg doesn't look
perfectly real stylize it it helps yeah
that's a very good point now you're
injecting intent into your shot it's
like i wanted it to look like this as
opposed to i wanted to look like this
other thing and i couldn't quite get
there you know what we are going to do
it we are going to do an entirely
dedicated love death and robots episode
but we need some comments recommending
which of the episodes we're going to
cover because we're not going to be able
to cover all of them we need some
recommendations leave a comment down
below or as sam says do a comment
it's been the most requested thing so
far this year and that is the she-hulk
trailer
because we didn't ask for this
so far bruce is looking nice bruce has
been looking nice for years exactly
they've literally been working on them
for over a decade this shot looks
incredible this is probably the best
looking shot in the whole trailer for me
you're definitely right i think she's
full cg out here she's 100 yeah is she
actually cg for the whole thing i feel
like there's a few shots in here that
they just green her up no she is this
shot she's 100 cg
that looks cg to me no it doesn't it's
like the movement i believe it's real
it's like the weird like motion blur or
something
yes it's going back and forth from
utterly convincing to shrek shrek
people have been complaining about the
she-hulk vfx and it's it kind of comes
as a long journey of a lot of general
hate towards the marvel movies and how
bad their cgi has been and their overuse
of it and i think it's just been a
little bit of a
misdirection of angst i don't know how
to describe it it's like they're getting
angry that marvel keeps using all the
cgi but it's not really the cgi itself
that is bad what is up with this like
why is it that every trailer has to be
like controversial or something i don't
know yeah why do people get i don't get
why anyone's getting worked up about
this there are so many people that are
saying that the she-hulk vfx are
absolute garbage now i'm not going to
say they're wrong i mean they are
although they are totally wrong
these aren't garbage v effects
well i don't get it i just this is this
is like this dumb internet culture of
like pretending to dunk on things it's
like just don't see it like you don't
need to tell people it's bad like
everyone will make their own mind up
preach it sam preach this is the best
date i've had in a while oh
this looks great this looks great yeah i
think this looks great for being 100 cgi
most of the shots in this trailer look
fantastic and this being one of them
obviously it's a close-up so it needs to
hit right you can't punch in on a janky
shot but like what is triggering their
minds to be like this is garbage i think
i've kind of identified why
there's an issue first off people were
reacting to the youtube trailer which
was compressed because of the
compression that they exported it out as
and then uploaded it to youtube that
smoothed out all of those details so you
end up with a very like sort of rubbery
smooth green look this shot you can see
it right away typically in pop culture
women's faces are very like smooth you
know comparing her to say bruce banner
mark ruffalo's hulk there's so much
detail there that we can see that
compression just will not be able to
remove i recognize beard crow's feet
wrinkles on the forehead the way his
mouth is scrunched and these wrinkles
here he's got freaking grizzly beard
stubble going on he's got wrinkles all
around his face you don't have stubble
on women which is a detailed thing that
you can simulate to kind of help make
something have more detail he doesn't
sit in the uncanny valley for us one
because he doesn't look that much like a
human his face is square he's just
freaking hulked out chad up in here and
two we're just so used to it at this
point that it doesn't trigger our senses
the same way that she-hulk is doing i
just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer that shot right here this is the
shot that i think most people have been
reacting negatively to yes there is some
smoothness going on but it's also the
animation of the face it feels the
uncanny valley it's like gummy and like
yeah well they're setting out to do one
of the hardest things ever and let's
make a cg person sure two or three shots
aren't like flawlessly perfectly
convincing over the course of a series
once you start watching it you watch the
show for five minutes and then suddenly
you just start taking the character at
face value and even if a shot isn't as
perfect as the other shots like you stop
caring pretty quickly because you're not
sitting there raiding every shot in this
series anymore you're just you're
enjoying it yeah
granted the story will be good and
you'll come the characters will be
compelling and you'll be focused on that
i think it's the expectation that
marvel's at the top and anything less
than perfect is unacceptable that's the
best summary here they've just outdone
themselves time and time again the bar
is so high they have to reach this
almost unattainable bar yet they achieve
it every time and if it's just two
percent below the bar it's like
it seems like this trailer is a really
good segue for some other cool vfx with
that same actress yeah this whole video
is honestly just a tatiana maslany
appreciation video
[Music]
have you noticed anything notable about
this scene it's it's strange they're
they're they're dancing it's one actress
and it's the same actress playing all
these very very different characters and
every single character here is such a
different person and i buy it 100 and
yet they interact with each other let's
follow the guy who's grinding all right
i want to watch all the interactions he
makes with the scene and then we can
judge what's really on set while he's
doing it
so he was almost interacting with her
but he steps around that one who just
stood up
all right
he moves the cg table it's not a cg
table definitely
no touch
okay kind of oh blocked touch oh but
they are tight so he interacts with her
but he dodged probably like a tennis
ball or something earlier that shot's
actually much less complicated than it
appears to be he is the
anchor to the entire scene he's the
thing that is able to interact with
multiple versions of her okay so notice
how he goes off frame and then comes
back in frame every time he goes off
frame it's a different shot a shot like
that requires so much coordination they
had bits of the ground taped out and
choreographed ahead of time so
everything about that dance scene was so
meticulously choreographed the placement
the timing of where they're dancing it
seems like they're just kind of casually
dancing but they are very carefully
hitting multiple marks so they don't
pass through each other so they do not
pass through each other exactly and the
second thing is that they also have
multiple body doubles that look very
good if you cannot see the face if
you're viewing it from slightly behind
you can't tell that it's not actually
her and so they're getting away with a
lot of these shots by basically just
doing that yeah but for the big wide
shot where the camera's moving through
the room it is just her in every shot
and they're having to do multiple
different takes through the entire scene
of her dancing so that they can stitch
it all together after the fact that is a
classic clone type shot
that table that he's moving it's not a
cg table it's a real table look at that
context shadow is garbage no but like
literally look at the funky shadows on
the feet they look like these little
triangles yeah they were just like dude
we gotta end the shadow somewhere
table is real he's physically moving it
off but i think they rotoscoped out the
table and didn't take any of the ground
and shadows with it and so they had to
manually add back in the shadow and it
was literally just a big circle
underneath it was a cd floor
small tidbit on this they actually what
they did in compositing was they brought
an image of a potato
in and they turned it 3d flattened it
below the table uh set the color just to
pure black feathered it yeah attract it
to the table so
i think you're right it's a potato
definitely yeah it's faster to bring in
like a picture of a potato yeah it's
like draw a circle usually sometimes
sometimes with that plug-in with the
plug-in it's good
okay so i don't know this actress well
enough to know this is the same person
it just looks like a fight scene between
two people which is probably a good
thing the show works so well because you
forget it's the same actress playing all
these different characters you're just
you're seeing characters and forget that
it's the same person
be able to do that arm over the foot
that took hours i'd imagine so to be
clear this show has zero
cgi
for this effect there's visual effects
happening but no cgi like this is yeah
all real footage and blocking and
choreography and rehearsal and just
really really good timing and
performance tons of rotoscoping wait a
second so they filmed this with a double
yeah and then they had to take out the
double and put the other actress in and
match up her legs wow far more difficult
that foot is coming from so where is the
foot coming from it could be an asset
collection it could be
i'm serious
i think what we're seeing is a
frankenstein image of her leg using
elements from the body double and
elements from tatiana maslany watch her
leg as the transition happens her leg
changes but her body doesn't yeah yeah
yeah 100 and so that is a different leg
there and it could be from the body
double it could be from a different take
my theory is that they did two takes
with the actors switching roles and in
one take she rolls over and the foot's
under the left armpit and then another
take the foot under the right armpit and
so instantly we have blocking that
doesn't match up or in a line so they
have to go back and fix the original
take to match what happened in the later
take with the double instantly we were
like whoa look at that cool leg
interaction and it turns out if we dive
deeper i think the source of why that
like interaction is there in the first
place is because that's actually them
having to merge two separate
performances like they're both very
close but not quite and so that leg ends
up being the thing that actually unifies
this all i mean whatever okay maybe
we're wrong what do you think what how
did they do this and if you want to let
us know do a comment
do one just do one do a comment sorry
hey do a comment do a comment do a
comment now
thankfully everyone leaves comments uh
someone told us that matt you are not
subscribed matt i think it's time you
went over to that little button give it
a click show your support for the
youtube channel so yeah matt if you're
still watching you know click that
button hey matt do it for me yeah there
we go let's simplify this matt subscribe
for rem
[Music]
let's expose the pizzeria holy jumping
canada is a little fuzzy eh so this is a
classic clone shot static camera not
moving shoot each actor doing a
different performance on either half of
the frame look at his left hand he clips
the freaking blue screen here he clips
it
it's fine we all make mistakes i get it
we've been looking at this for like less
than a minute and there dude we're like
the navy seals
this is like all right let's see the
shot oh where's there
all right
all right boys we're done we're done
with this show i was literally just
pointing out how this is like the
simplest effect you can possibly do no
i've made that error for sure i i've
made that error too i i feel bad kind of
dunking on it because it's an accident
that's one of those things that's like
someone just missed it that's on the
super that's on the freaking that's
called not watching your shop before you
render it yeah
which you know i've done it so to
conclude this shot anyways she is
probably in one or the other original
shot and then he's acting alone in the
other shot and they're just comping it
together the camera's static it's very
easy to do somehow they still
made a mistake i i feel bad that we've
now pointed this out whoever did that i
i'm
sorry it happens to the best of us sorry
but
you know as you can see there's many
levels of ambition when it comes to
clone shots you know are we just going
to slap it on a tripod split screen are
we going to get like motion controlled
cameras are we going to film different
plates on green screens and then track
them into the shot there's so
many techniques but like that kind of
like wraps them all up everything beyond
that is like gemini man at that point
where it's just like full cg people
don't you hate when these episodes end
don't you feel like there's a little bit
more well on our website if you
subscribe to it we have extended cuts of
these episodes so we can you know
prolong the entertainment just a little
bit longer give you a little more toilet
time maybe you're only halfway through
your cereal bowl or your giant english
breakfast i thought you're gonna say
halfway through something else after
that toilet comment hey i get it you're
a parent and you finally have a few
moments to get away from your kids by
sitting on the toilet well if you need a
few more minutes quarterdigital.com this
episode's longer there
[Music]
things aren't always cool calm and
collected around the studio
things tend to get a little messy but
that's fine that's why i trust bessie
today's sponsor
so what are vessies well they're some of
the most stylish and versatile sneakers
i've personally ever worn you can dress
them up or dress them down wear them all
around town the coolest thing about
besties to me is they're made from this
dimetex material so they keep your feet
cold in the summer and warm in the
winter but also one of my favorite
things is that well they're 100
waterproof
look at that it's like coffee never got
spilt on it and then if i put my hand in
there
completely dry completely dry
and they don't smell into a bacterial
soul jordan there's an ant on you oh you
want me to kill it oh no no no no
bessies are 100 vegan which means that
no animals were hurt in the making of
this shoe so none are gonna be harmed
right now a little anti
in a world full of chaos that's usually
highly unpredictable it's great to have
a shoe that helps bring order and
comfort into any circumstance of your
life so if you want order and you want
comfort go to bessie.com quarter crew so
you can get 25 off of each pair of
bessies that's bessie.com corridor crew
and remember say yesi to vessi hey thank
you so much for watching this episode
and thank you clint
for joining us again on this lovely
couch i love hearing your thoughts on
all these cool clips and as you continue
on your own path you gain more and more
insights that i'm always eager to hear
yeah that means a lot sam uh it's good
to be back with you guys feels like home
feels like head and left it's great to
come back i'm glad now get out go go the
door's right there i'll take the mic
yo we don't have we don't have a
recycling you gotta go the recycling's
over there yeah you're still down for
lunch or no or no man you gotta go i'm
full yeah all right you guys probably
take your mic back there's a bucket
outside you can put it in there